el clima le juega una mala pasada a la
conmemoración del día del trabajo en
Cuba las Fuertes lluvias en la región
occidental obligaron al gobierno de
díaz-canel a posponer el tradicional
desfile del primero de mayo la lluvia en
buena parte del país nos impedirá salir
a festejar el primero de mayo no
cancelamos la celebración la posponemos
para el próximo día 5 la van a recibió
el azote de una tormenta con
precipitaciones fuertes vientos Y
descargas eléctricas que dejó calles
inundadas y daños materiales los
habitantes de la capital dicen que no
han recibido ayuda de las autoridades
más de 15 días
[Música]
no ha venido nadie yo soy una de las que
decía para poder liberar nuestras vidas
nadie hasta ahora que se cayó eso ahí se
ha caído todo lo perdimos todo hacemos
agua tenemos comida tenemos nada Cuba ya
había suspendido el desfile de la Plaza
de la Revolución debido a la crisis de
combustible normalmente decenas de miles
de participantes llegan en autobuses de
toda la ciudad para reunirse en esta
emblemática Plaza de la capital antes de
marchar la isla atraviesa su peor crisis
económica en 30 años bajo los efectos
combinados de las consecuencias de la
pandemia el refuerzo de las sanciones
estadounidenses y las debilidades
estructurales internas esta situación
está provocando una escasez recurrente
de alimentos medicinas y gasolina
agravada por una inflación galo